vai botar o oita botar a comunidade se
lançou daniel e tive aqui hoje haverá
muitas pessoas nas suas palestras a
falarem de experiências que tiveram na
sua vida e que não fume mostraram que de
alguma forma mudaram absorveram a ser
como era o seu caráter e que o gênio que
falar hoje são expressões de
experiências e aprendem muito mais
insignificantes escola não teríamos
muita importância mas que eu agora
olhando para trás vai trouxe
fundamentais no meu percurso desde 1 mil
diz socialmente neste quadro que nunca
estaria aqui falar em público e que não
tenha muito interesse nem sequer saber
muito bem como lidar com os humildes nem
interesse nisso e até olhava para os
negócios e para as empresas concertos
bem vindos como a fonte de todo mal do
nosso mundo
isso porque no mundo real a vez do
espaço nem freezer nem roque importantes
sobre as empresas e agora e eu no fundo
foi uma transformação desse modo como
está aqui hoje que essa aumentativo
procurou os outros porque desconhece uma
imensidão de capacidade
uma imensidão de experiências que nunca
no meu curto tempo de vida poderia vir a
explorar dominaram a ter todas e que no
fundo a conhece que essas experiências e
se expressar fundamentais não só no meu
na minha melhoria na minha função
enquanto pessoa mas também no
desenvolvimento de projetos conjuntos
poderão eventualmente dia de negócios
que apesar de poderem vir a ser tudo mal
também tem uma vala comum capacidade
para trazer mudanças positivas no nosso
mundo
o jetta é assim e só vamos falar de
quando andava na primária
a minha escola organizava uma folha da
ladra anual
ora nessa falha do annual eu e os meus
amigos
quer dizer os meus colegas vá dando
problema da mix
temos uma oportunidade de jogar nos
nossos brinquedos
nós já não estavam os três e os pais
escola e trocá-los no fundo por
brinquedos novos
o dinheiro para fazer o que eu quisesse
no fundo comprar gomas sem ter que
prestar contas a ninguém porque é o
nosso patrimônio e adaptativa da criança
especial
mas também oficial de outra perspectiva
pensem comigo
no fundo eu enquanto cresce o que eu
tinha que fazer
tenho aqui pra casa e avaliar o meu
patrimônio
tinha que ver quase eram os 20% dos
brinquedos que mais eficazmente
descumpriam a tarefa de fazer foi isso
que é compreendam os oito que no fundão
80% da felicidade numa numa coleção que
é considerada que é muito usada na
gravação preto e tem de olhar depois
para os outros 80% os brinquedos no
fundo eram as ordens e tentar perceber
que o valor é que poderiam ter para quem
é que poderia ter valor e tentar
estabelecer um preço com base nisso e no
seu estado atual
por que tentar saber quanto é que vão
obviamente que é para a pista mas só tem
uma perna
eu também não precisa de espera na
explosão para quedas importantes a uma
zona depois senha para a minha
mercadoria transportá la para a escola e
não fazer um esforço de vendas tenha
tentarem impedir que o admite que não
podia comprar aqui os outros brinquedos
que eu criei é muito menos gomas e um o
que eu aprendi com essa experiência o
que aprender com essa experiência foi
que através do exercício simples qual a
motivação e que na altura não nos quer
pensava nisso mas agora olhando para
trás penso nisso
aprendi como fazer um esforço de vendas
como advogada com
um é um produto aprendi com menos
quebrei pelo menos um certo estigma
mental um certo mas certas barreiras
mentais que nós quando pensamos por
exemplo em vender algo alguém do que
menos porque nunca tivemos essa
experiência não porque seja difícil
porque não temos a nossa zona de
conforto e no fundo do moncada se dessa
zona de conforto e com apenas seis
acertantes na altura também quando
andava na primária é o um nome uma
tempestade que assolou completamente
destruiu escolas pokémon esse tema
estava era aquilo que todos os mil dias
criam os garçons saberem falar sempre
tenham tempo disponível e na altura nós
queremos saber alguma coisa do tipo mas
eu pedi erro incrível
o pedro tem fraquezas aqui nós não temos
outra solução senão perguntar ao sul
tímidos porque na altura ainda nove
internet usada como agora e e pois não
bastava perguntar um sonho porque dizer
qual é a credibilidade como descer tanto
tempo mil
não é assim tanto combinam o produto há
três ou quatro é fazer uma espécie com
silvio só para debater a questão dentro
do nível de evolução do pid mas
rapidamente grandes conseguiam e outros
1.500 suas próprias dúvidas e questões
que queriam saber coisas também
levantavam os eslavos toda uma discussão
poderia durar uma hora ou duas horas por
dia na altura já estávamos a discutir
todos os pokémon de qualquer os meus
porque moniz e que taxe que prende o
equívoco e eu estamos muito tempo nisto
mas a verdade é que enquanto nós temos
pokémon como o próprio futuro do país
pendesse isso tá vamos aprender a trocar
idéias
vamos aprender a dar a nossa opinião
vamos aprender a ouvir a opinião dos
outros
vamos aprender que quando a discussão é
conduzida no bem comum
verdadeiramente conduzida no bem comum
toda a gente ficar ganha perto de nós
ficávamos saber é que o crime cv e ainda
mais como saber o que os outros queriam
saber que você vem da mágica e
tudo isso num ambiente mantendo sempre
né
um tudo isso melhora a auto motivação
depois pokémon não se gastou
sou jogos gambóias série ou os filmes
nosso gol
eu tinha que ficar com esta manhã então
eu eo time djavan de cargas pokémon e
como conseqüência quase natural isso
evoluímos pronto jogo talvez alguns de
vocês poderão estar valorizado que médio
integrado em que o jogo esteja com
cartas e hoje foi um jogo acompanhou
desde o básico até aqui a universidade
durante o verão muitos anos e como
sempre os garotos o aumento com os
amigos nas graças dos outros mercados
uns dos outros na escola mas não tanto
para nos roubarem as cartas mas também e
e conforme o fim dos entes e conforme
paixão por jogo que foi aumentando em
seis linguagens de novo
minha mãe é minha paixão
o jogo foi quente porque a minha
compreensão a minha capacidade de
compressão jogo também foi pequeno e
conforme essa capacidade de criação foi
de compressão foi a minha forma de
compreensão também foi crescente e eu
comecei a escrever cartas é que eu sei
na próxima coleção cv este apoio do
milagre da internet no site oficial
mas comecei a escrever como é que ela
estava ser desenhadas e foi querendo ler
mais e foi mais cedo como já estava se
desenhando como é que estava a ser
pensado com a sac nos fios fias estavam
em jogo que estava em causa até que a
dada altura já o humor típico todos os
dias em inglês e muitos deles bastante
extenso e alguns até com certas questões
filosóficas provavelmente na altura não
não entenderia na sua plenitude mas que
no fundo sem serem directamente sobre
como julgar melhor
foram tornando mim um jogador
visivelmente melhor e eu sentisse né na
prática porque eu sabia todas as cartas
vocês não querem que se vê como é que
tudo funcionava e porque isso é
importante
isso é importante porque foi aí que eu
percebi o verdadeiro poder de compressão
funda quando nós percebemos com maio
mesmo com prendemos um maio e sabemos
quase pra ver como é que vai vir antes
das coisas acontecerem
e foi através do médico isso
além disso mais tarde é o pé da minha
casa e abrir uma loja que criou todo um
ambiente mais constantes
percebi que eu já escrevi pokémon nem
toda a gente devia respirava medic e que
estou nível de seriedade do jogo pra mim
pô uma outra escala
outra coisa que eu também aprendi comedy
que se calhar alguns de vocês não têm
consciência mas quem conhece o jogo
celebrar é que foi o momento para mim o
primeiro grande contato com a lei da
oferta e da procura
quero que temos quer não reze em parte
ou em boa parte das coisas do nosso dia
a dia e resta meio médico porque há
cartas comuns em alguns e raras
antes tem abundância e têm preços
diferentes causa disso e em média as
cartas já era sua máscara máscaras que
assim com onze e meia sem uns são mais
caras do que as comuns porque há mais
como os negros que as casas mas podem
ver comuns mais caras do que as noras
simplesmente porque ninguém gosta
daquelas raras que elas não prestam e
por isso ninguém quer jogar com elas e
toda sem que haja qualquer os comuns e
mais dentro das regras
agora acho que valem 50 cêntimos e agora
se fala em 50 euros
simplesmente por causa da procura e não
foi o que eu pretendo dizer com isto que
eu pretendo dizer que o estudo é que há
uma série de capacidades fundamentais
como já disse de compressão do mercado
de valor da comunidade de emissão e
compreensão que são fundamentais
atualmente hoje na moda de
empreendedorismo que hoje vivemos e
podem ser adquiridas e novamente a ter
mas só podem ser adquiridas neste tipo
de maio neste mais informais não é não é
fácil de aprender nas aulas não se pode
aprender problemas ao tentar praticar
tem que fazer e yo-yo é isso que eu
pretendo aqui esse tipo de atividade
sejam pensadas sejam valorizadas por que
essa moda empreendorismo tem sido feita
nesta moda de empreendedorismo estamos a
viver mas com pressões têm sido feitas
nos estados unidos mas quer fazer essas
comparações com estados unidos
raras são as pessoas falam da cultura
que está em de vendas de bols
porta-a-porta vendas dominada em bancas
vendem geraldinho de garagem de da
importância que a escola que mais logo
na escola secundária rainha as bandas
têm equipas desportivas têm os grupos de
ciência o teatro e qual é impossível por
exemplo pode ser expressos universitária
lá comparativamente há cá e é todas
estas coisas não fazem parte dessa
cultura empreendedora por meio da minha
opinião porque fizemos uma criança de
seis anos 70 anos que tem uma banca
dominada em produzir um produto que tem
que agradar os clientes têm que tentar
vender outras duas forças vendas e tem
que cuidar com feedback do cliente tem
que lidar com o cliente dizer onde
discutiu a assumir nada não está muito
boa e sim em ser difícil para uma
criança de seis anos 70 antes mas vai
ser pior quando o jogo for a sério e as
coisas primeiro é mesmo disso no fundo
espero que esse toque que tenho que dar
nos seja útil e que têm de ir pra
aprender uma coisa com isso a tomar
alguma iniciativa nas nossas comunidades
recessão isto senão esse assunto é ser
top foi péssima só quer perceber isto é
que eu fui só assinado mas outro colega
ou seja dois de nove possíveis
candidaturas por looks ou num critério
poderá ter sido convidado a oportunidade
talvez mas isso em 2009 mas me ajudado a
esconder estiveram abertas toda a
universidade não só da nossa foi acusado
de ter havido qualquer coisa como cerca
de 1.800
candidaturas de todos os alunos mas não
houve um só 900 1800
portanto o primeiro critério de exclusão
não foi convidade primeiro critério de
exclusão foi iniciativa
portanto primeira vez se sustentar e
pois é preciso ser bom
obrigado